(cheering)
- You're going to teach us how
to do Riverdance, I assume.
- Exactly, yes.
- Riverdance is like the end
all, be all of step dancing,
and it's like girls with curly wigs.
Did you bring any of
the little curly wigs?
- I didn't, no.
- Oh. Too bad.
- Sorry, Zach.
- Can we do a close up on his teeth!
- You're gonna wanna see those teeth.
- Look at Ned's gross teeth
compared to those pearly whites.
- It makes my teeth look awful.
- We're gonna roll our shoulders back,
put superglue on our arms, keep those in.
- Ooh!
- And we're gonna put them
right at the side seams.
- Are you grabbing your butt?
- No.
- Do you grab your butt at this point?
- No butt action.
- Are you sure?
- While we're beginners,
like, if it helps us,
can we just like grab our butts?
- Very beginners hold on to their shirts.
- Oh, that's great.
- It's already Zane.
- We haven't even started dancing.
- We haven't started this,
we're just standing here.
- That's the problem.
- We're going to bring our left foot
all the way up to our butt.
Kick.
- This is the step for five year olds?
- This is like the first thing you learn.
- (beep) Zane!
- One, two three, three, three.
All right.
- Four.
Four, jackasses.
- Back, two, three, back, two three.
- (beep) (beep) Zane!
- How would you rate us all individually?
- I think you guys's
guess of Eugene being best
might have been true.
- Ooh.
- It's okay, I just come to accept it.
- All right, these guys
are gonna need lots of
practice and work.
So if they want to
impress their co-workers,
may the luck of the Irish be with them.
- Who do you think's gonna
look the most adorable
in a vest?
- Am I supposed to answer that?
- As someone who dances, I didn't realize
Irish step dance was
really, really, really hard.
And that it takes a lot of
powerful gluteous skills.
Yeah, I feel like my butt is
so much tauter, and tighter.
- Mostly, I gotta say, I
just wanna make Zane proud.
- To Zane.
- To Zane!
- To Zane's teeth.
- Well, to all of Zane,
but mostly his teeth.
- No, 90% his teeth.
- Yeah, 10% Zane.
(burp)
(traditional Irish music)
- I've found that coordinating
all of my limbs at once
is nearly impossible.
But focusing on just two,
just two of my four limbs,
has been a real plus
in my dancing ability.
- There's something
about eight-year-old Ned
that saw Riverdance on
TV and was inspired.
I think a little bit of that
joy was rekindled today.
- It challenges your body in places,
like muscles I didn't
know could be challenged
by tapping around.
- Eugene. Come on, Eugene.
- Eugene.
- We're not shotgunning this?
(cheering)
- I almost slipped at one point,
I thought I was gonna bust myself,
but none of it mattered.
All you did was smile,
you picked your feet up,
and you danced in time to the music.
- I just thought about
Zane's teeth, and I was good.
- [All] Zane's teeth,
Zane's teeth, Zane's teeth,
Zane's teeth, Zane's teeth, Zane's teeth.
- Hearts, stars, and horseshoes.
- Clovers and blue moons.
- Pots of golds and rainbows.
- And Zane's teeth.
- I said pots of golds.
- Whatever.
- Ooh!
- All right, the video's done.